>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Stephen Winick:
Hello, I'm Steven Winnick.
This is the Library of
Congress, and I'm here
with a group called Newpoli,
who perform music
from Southern Italy.
I am the writer and editor in
the American Folklife Center
of the Library of Congress and
I'm trained as a folklorist.
And we just presented
Newpoli in concert
in our Homegrown Concert Series.
So these are three members of
the group Newpoli, and I'm going
to ask each of you
to say your name.
>> Carmen Marsico: My
name is Carmen Marsico.
>> Angela Rossi: And my
name is Angela Rossi.
>> Bjorn Wennas: My
name is Bjorn Wennas.
>> Stephen Winick: And these
are, as I said, three members
of the group Newpoli who perform
music from Southern Italy.
So let's begin with the
question, how many members
of the band are actually
from Southern Italy?
>> Carmen Marsico: Three
members actually, yes.
Three members are from the
South in different parts.
One is me and I'm
from Basilicata.
My family is from Basilicata.
>> Angela Rossi: And
then I am from Naples,
like my family is from Naples.
And then there's
Fabio Pirozzolo.
>> Carmen Marsico:
There's Fabio--
Yeah, there is also from
the lowest part of Lazio,
which is Southern pat of Rome.
So Terracina is actually
the name of his town.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hmm.
And that--
>> Bjorn Wennas: Maybe
we should give a shout
out to Dan, our band--
>> Angela Rossi: That's right.
>> Carmen Marsico: OK.
Yeah, that's true.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Because this
[inaudible] we come up here.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: All
right, excellent, yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: And as we--
And as I always like
to joke about it.
He's from Northern
Italy as you can tell.
>> Stephen Winick:
Yeah, that's right.
>> Bjorn Wennas: The
very north of Italy.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Angela Rossi: Region
called Sweden [laughter].
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
And so, other members of the
group are from other places,
some American and
some from Europe.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yes, yeah.
Correct.
>> Stephen Winick: And so,
how did you come together
as a group around Italian music?
>> Angela Rossi: That's
in [foreign language].
>> Carmen Marsico: Yes.
>> Angela Rossi: So we--
well, we have had, you know,
changing personnel in the group
over-- throughout the years.
But we met at Berklee
College of Music
where we were all studying
really modern music,
jazz specifically,
blues and other styles.
And one day, we were-- we all
met at the library at Berklee
and we noticed that there
was a wonderful international
folk festival.
They were helding it at the
Berklee Performance Center,
which is a really
nice room at Berklee.
And we noticed that Italy
wasn't represented, so we--
our pride came out, you know.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah,
actually haven't been
represented almost ever,
only once they did it but they--
it was done by
Italian-Americans,
and they did not
play a folk music.
They play, you know, more
like the Jazz Italian.
>> Angela Rossi: Right.
>> Carmen Marsico: And so we
thought, well, we need to do it.
>> Angela Rossi: Yes,
to bring, you know,
the real authentic music.
And since, you know, Carmen
and I were both from the South
of Italy and we were exposed
since we were really young
to these styles, we just
said, oh, we can, you know--
we weren't doing
it as a, you know,
before then as a professional
or anything, but we said, well,
we should try to
prepare some music
and we submitted it,
see what was there.
And we-- you know, they
selected us and so we performed,
and we really enjoyed
it and we decided
to make it something more
serious and start a research
at that point, you know, to
widen the repertoire and such.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hmm.
That's a great story.
But it also touches on
something interesting which is
that in the US, you
have movements
around certain ethnic folk music
like Irish music and
things like that.
But Italian music
doesn't seem to be
as well represented
even though there are
so many Italian-Americans.
>> Angela Rossi: It's true.
>> Stephen Winick: Have
you gotten a sense of why
that is through your--
>> Angela Rossi:
I have an opinion.
I don't know if I have a
sense but I have an opinion.
I think that that some
older generations,
I think now is a little bit
better, we are progressing.
But in the first immigration
especially, people were really--
Italian immigrants
were very afraid
of not integrating
properly with the culture,
with the American culture
especially their kids,
their children.
Sometimes they wouldn't
even teach them Italian.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi So I think
it might have something
to do with that.
>> Carmen Marsico: I think
they were a little bit ashamed.
I mean, they kind
of repressed the--
>> Bjorn Wenna: There was a lot
of racists towards Italians--
>> Carmen Marsico:
Yeah, exactly.
Because they couldn't really
speak well English, so they kind
of erased a little bit--
>> Bjorn Wennas: I think your
opinion is probably correct.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: Yeah.
And now-- you know, though,
there is a really nice--
we're so glad because I feel
like the newer generations,
you know, that are coming, the
new immigrations so to speak,
they're more interested
in keeping the traditional
life, so.
>> Carmen Marsico:
What I actually noticed
that even Italian-American are--
I'm receiving more like people,
oh, this is amazing, I want to
research more about my roots.
So now-- I mean, now, it's
been probably five years or so
that Italian-American
are more interested
in rediscovering their roots.
>> Stephen Winick: Interesting.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: So,
your immigrant experience was
coming here to be musicians.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: And you
kind of shifted the type
of music that you play though.
So what was that like coming
to the United States to work
as musicians or to
learn as musicians?
>> Carmen Marsico: Well,
I mean I guess we were a little
bit lucky because we studied--
all three of us studied
at Berklee
where there was so
much diversity.
So it was fantastic actually,
it was really wonderful
to hear different cultures and
explore different sounds and,
you know, become richer
and richer as a musician
because you could really
absorb all those influences.
I really enjoyed-- I
still enjoy it actually,
now-- even now, yeah.
>> Stephen Winick:
And you want-- yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas: I agree
with what she said.
No, I would say that one thing
that I think that everybody
that studied at Berklee
experience was that a lot
of teachers there, they
want you to go and look
in your roots and, you know,
see what you can bring.
So I think that,
you know, that--
maybe like the shift towards--
for them, shifts towards
playing folk music
from back home was maybe
not that big of a shift,
you know, that's the--
>> Angela Rossi: It
wasn't that far fetch.
It's true.
Because what you do is you're
integrating-- those are--
yeah, relate to that
because you're integrated,
you're studying the
American styles of singing
and playing and-- but you're
exposed to so much, different--
so many different things.
And then what happens is that
you start sort of going back
to what can I contribute?
What's my unique voice?
And I think partly is that
you are so far removed
from your origins that you
really can look with a sort
of a more like a neutral and see
that that's very
special, you know.
When you're there, maybe you
don't appreciate it as much.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, right.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: So
When you were there,
were you mostly interested
in American musical styles?
Is that what--
>> Angela Rossi: I would
say-- I mean, I'm--
first of all, we
all have our own--
>> Stephen Winick: Sure, yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: --
you know, obviously.
So I was-- I really was drawn
to jazz primarily and blues
and some of the, you
know, the good rock,
British rock and roll.
And I've-- yeah, I'm
not ashamed of it,
you know, like I'm American--
>> Bjorn Wennas: I
was going to say it,
say it like you also
like Metallica.
>> Angela Rossi:
I love Metallica.
I love Metallica, but I was
trained-- classically trained.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Angela Rossi: And even,
you know-- And so it's, yeah,
it's sort of interesting
background.
A lot of Europeans have this, by
the way, you know, this exposure
to all these, they seem
so opposite in a way
but they're not, you
know, it's all music.
And so, that's kind of
where my influence is
where if you can see
that, you know, at first.
And then I kind of went
towards where music more--
and then more and more as I
was, you know, exploring things.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
Was that true for
you as well, Carmen?
>> Carmen Marsico:
I mean, I-- as--
I mean I actually
started within--
I was kind of trained
classically for a little bit,
but I kind of like the
R&B the, the American R&B.
And then I started being
interested in jazz because I am
at this jazz British-Egyptian
singer that played
with this [inaudible]
for a little bit.
They actually think they were
lovers, but-- and then it was--
I was-- I fell in
love, I couldn't stop,
but I have to say, when-- at
that time, she was the one
that maybe stared make me think
a little bit because she decided
to record this famous
song, "A Night in Tunisia"
in Egyptian instead of English.
And I was like, woah, and then
the whole-- it wasn't really,
you know, swing, it was done
with this really
amazing African rhythm.
And I was like so
absorbed by that,
it was like I really like that.
And then the next kind of step
it was to discover Shubin.
For me, it was a big discovery
because I couldn't
stop listening to them.
I felt that, that type of
music was little closer
to how I felt music
compared to just
to swing, more natural for me.
So, yeah, and then little
by little, you know,
when you start exploiting the
Brazilians style then the Latin
style, the Cuban and then
you get to the Africa.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Carmen Marsico: It was
kind of like going back
to the roots like that.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Fabio,
though, they [inaudible].
He did play folk music in Italy.
>> Angela Rossi: Right.
He really professionally--
the tambourine--
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: -- in Italy
in several traditional groups
before he came to Boston
where he also studied, you know,
modern styles and jazz and--
>> Carmen Marsico:
Yes, and jazz.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
Mm-hmm. And Bjorn--
>> Carmen Marsico:
Yeah, what about you?
>> Stephen Winick: -- what
was your musical background?
>> Bjorn Wennas: My musical
background is classical guitar,
that's how I started.
Then I quickly shifted
to a lot of metal.
So, several hardcore
groups that I played
in back home and more groups.
But at some point, I started
playing jazz, that's how I got
over to Berklee College of Music
and then I met this
wonderful lady.
>> Carmen Marsico: Well, I want
to say something about Bjorn,
the-- he always forgot to say.
When we-- yeah--
>> Bjorn Wennas: We're
married, you can tell her.
>> Angela Rossi: There you go.
There you go.
>> Carmen Marsico: When we were
looking for a guitar player,
we first asked this Italian
guy, that was a jazz player
and he said, this is not what
I really do, and then we--
we're already dating
and he had play
for me this amazing Swedish
folk group and I was like, wow,
so things are similar to what--
how we embellished music.
And so, when Angela and
I asked him and he said,
oh, yeah, I'd love to.
And then-- I mean he had this,
I don't know, new eyes to look
at the stuff and but at
the same time he have
in his mind even though
he doesn't say, but he--
I mean Swedish like
culture like their folk,
traditional is so strong.
>> Angela Rossi: Yes.
>> Carmen Marsico: Even if they
don't maybe, you know, think so
but it's still part of
them the way they are.
>> Angela Rossi: The
strings and the--
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: -- the value
of singing is very strong--
>> Carmen Marsico: So, he never
had the problem to understand
like the grooves
or like you know--
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
Pretty much all the
arrangements and most
of the original music
that we play, I did.
The Swedish eyes--
>> Carmen Marsico: He had
the right sensitivity.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
So who was this Swedish
group that you talk about?
>> Bjorn Wennas: Oh, Frifot.
>> Stephen Winick: Oh, Frifot.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: You know them?
>> Stephen Winick: I do.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Carmen Marsico: Unbelievable.
Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: And you know,
I just-- it's interesting.
I just-- I was just thinking
how all of us kind of came--
we really came from
studying jazz.
What happens is it's such a free
music, it's so free and the--
I think the improvisational
element is a thing
that makes you discover other--
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Angela Rossi: --
interesting aspects of the music
and also yeah, like
she was saying jazz had
different components.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: You know, jazz
is like general word but this--
the Latin, the Cuban,
so you realize
that what is his is
really-- the world of music--
the music of the world--
>> Carmen Marsico:
It's a lot of folk.
>> Angela Rossi: -- flows into
it, so yeah, there's a lot
of folk in it, basically, so.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
But another influence that
people might hear in Newpoli
and you'll tell me
if it's really there
or if it's just a coincidence,
is there really music?
>> Angela Rossi: Yes.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Oh no.
For sure.
>> Angela Rossi: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
So, how did that
get integrated into?
>> Bjorn Wennas: Well, I
mean like when you listen
to folk music in Italy,
they are still using a lot
of the same instruments.
And I think that, you
know, the crossover
between the early music and
the folk tradition there,
it's not a big step.
Two of our musicians in
the group, Dan and Karen,
they are flute player
and the violin is there.
They're actually
educated early musicians.
And I think that one of the
big reasons of why we pull them
into the band was two CDs ago,
we did a CD called Tempo Antico
where we did a lot
of renaissance music
but in a more of
a street folk way.
And yeah.
>> Carmen Marsico: Well--
>> Angela Rossi:
The-- yeah, go ahead.
>> Carmen Marsico:
I actually want
to say something about this.
Yeah. Because the
thing is that in Naples
in the renaissance time, they--
of course, there was
the educator early music
and not educator early music.
And so there's a bit, you know,
like discussion groups
to talk about.
The fact that the same composer,
maybe, perform the song
in a certain way at the court
and then instead on the street,
he would do it with the
folk musician, you know,
more like completely a little
rough and a little more edgy.
And I mean they don't know
exactly, of course, like--
but there's one specific
style that we did record
in Tempo Antico is the
Villanella alla Napolitana.
>> Angela Rossi: Right.
Right.
>> Carmen Marsico:
And that was what we--
When we did that we said, OK.
We want to present this
way, because we, you know,
we are kind of thinking
that probably on the street,
they were playing
the song like this.
But you know, in front of the
King, it was more refined.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Angela Rossi: Right.
Moresca as well.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Angela Rossi: The
moresca is another style,
carnivalistic style.
And many sounds are involved,
you know, the-- and that was--
our take was because we
heard a lot of those--
of this music, this material
performed classically really
perfectly with no--
>> Carmen Marsico: I think
there was also couple--
>> Angela Rossi: -- edge,
not a lot of-- yeah.
>> Carmen Marsico:
-- a couple of groups
that try to do it in the--
>> Angela Rossi: Right,
in the younger way.
>> Carmen Marsico: --
in this foreign way, so.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hmm.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yup.
>> Carmen Marsico: And--
[ Foreign Language ]
Exactly.
>> Angela Rossi: That was
really almost like the other--
the other way because they--
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah,
no, they play, yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: -- they really
even introduce the [inaudible].
I don't know if you're
familiar with them.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah,
I've heard of them.
Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: So
they introduce some even
electric instruments.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: And you know,
they definitely had a different
take on more folk and more edgy.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
They were definitely
a big influence
when we started doing
this music.
Absolutely.
>> Stephen Winick: Well--
So then another group that
I was familiar with growing
up because they're from New
York City was the group called I
Giullari di Piazza.
And I understand that
you've interacted
with them a little bit as well.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Well
not with the group per se
but with the guitarist, John
LaBarbera, he's a good friend
of ours and he actually played
on two of our albums, sorry.
And he was definitely one person
that I went to to learn from
and when it came to playing
the chitarra battente,
which he is a real master on.
And yeah but that's pretty much
the extent of our collaboration
but John definitely
taught us a lot
and was just always
supportive of the band.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Great.
>> Carmen Marsico: A
lot interesting stories.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Oh my God.
He has some interesting stories.
>> Angela Rossi: All right.
>> Bjorn Wennas:Get a ball
and a wine and that guy--
Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Angela Rossi: He's-- yeah,
he's traveled a lot and--
>>: Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
He was part of the
awakening of the folk music
in the Southern Italian folk
music in the '70s in Italy
and collaborated with a
lot of those people there.
And so-- playing with him was
kind of like I'm playing jazz
and I'm playing with
Charlie Parker.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bjorn Wennas: You know.
Yup.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
Well, what are things that they
had observed that group and John
in particular was that
because Italy was so important
in the development of classical
music, Italian folk styles
and the early music actually
had organic similarities,
is that something that
you've worked with as well?
>> Bjorn Wennas:
Well, maybe in the
like when we did Tempo Antico,
I think that we were
thinking about that a lot.
So, that was the album that we
use a lot of renaissance music
and try to re-imagine
it in a more folk way.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bjorn Wennas: But I think
from our previous in CD
in Nun Te Vuta and with the
CD that we recorded now,
we really wanted to turn it
completely different page
and write more of our own
music and in the style.
And also we wanted to look
at the entire area of the--
that surrounding Italy
and think about what kind
of influences may
or may not have come
in that influence
the folk music there.
And we wanted to like shine
a light on, say particularly
like recruit them or a
particular scale that, you know,
we could trace back to
something and, you know,
re-imagine the folk music
from those perspectives.
>> Carmen Marsico: Besides
also using the film recording.
>> Angela Rossi: Right.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hmm.
>> Carmen Marsico: As I--
well, some film recordings
are more like, OK, you listen
and it's like it's a song,
it's there and you can take it
and maybe, you know,
decide to do an introduction
and some sections in a certain
way, but others are really there
like those like-- I don't know--
or yeah, a woman singing in the
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, yeah.
>> Carmen Marsico: -- the
beginning of the songs is like,
oh cool and then she goes--
>> Angela Rossi: Out of tune.
>> Carmen Marsico: -- completely
out, and you're like, oh--
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah, it's--
>> Carmen Marsico: -- maybe she
didn't really want to do that,
so you have to imagine.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hmm.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
>> Carmen Marsico: But
still there's material
that you can use.
And one of the song that we
performed before during the
concert, then the flute player
was talking about, it's a chant
that has different variation,
different, I guess, way to sing.
It's really long too, we
didn't do the whole thing,
it's a little too long.
And-- but it's the-- we
collected this version close
to Matera in Basilicata
because of the time we thought,
oh we like this and
it's close to where--
how we feel it, but then I--
later on, even discover
the same chant--
like you could find a little
more in the center of Italy.
>> Angela Rossi: Let's
the name of the--
>> Carmen Marsico: It's
called fronidaliya [phonetic],
which means olive
branches, olive branches.
>> Angela Rossi: Yeah.
>> Carmen Marsico: And it sang
with a slightly different
dialect because, of course,
the dialect there is different.
So I don't know it's
like it's Bjorn said,
we discover like this
group from Greece or like--
but also I think the
film recordings are
like such a treasure.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hmm.
>> Carmen Marsico: So
sometimes by listening to one
of those things, we're like,
we could do this with this.
>> Stephen Winick: So where you
do find the field recordings
for Southern Italy
that you've used?
>> Carmen Marsico: So I
started researching online
because being here I couldn't
go deeply in, you know,
the library, but we have the
archival of Santa Cecilia
in Rome that has all those
recordings collected there.
And some professor that teaches
at different universities
have done like put together
like a book for-- by the region.
And so I bought the Basilicata
book even that Puglia,
I think about Calabria too.
Yeah. And I mean the
Basilicata was very dear to me
because it's my region.
And actually they say that
that was the first expedition,
expedition like going to
Africa, done, you need to be,
and it was done in 1952
by Diego Carpitella
and Ernesto De Martino
in the South of Italy.
And they specifically went
to Basilicata because at
that time was the most isolated
region and so they thought
that they would have been really
untouched and so like, you know,
they were really eager to
record whatever was there.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hmm.
>> Angela Rossi: And partly--
you know, particularly it
is true, you feel that way
when you hear those
recordings because I wasn't--
you know, I think that my
tradition was Neapolitan
and actually Carmen too, but she
was part-- she heard this music.
But, at first, I feel
like you were exposed also
to mostly Neapolitan music.
>> Carmen Marsico:
Mostly Neapolitan.
>> Angela Rossi: Because it's
the more famous one, right?
Even the [inaudible]
in Neapolitan.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
That was a big tradition
in my family like yours.
>> Angela Rossi: But when
she played this, you know,
recordings for me, I just-- oh
it really sounded like something
that had the elements
of Greece, of, you know,
some Arabic Middle East and
elements and the melodies and--
>> Carmen Marsico: Well,
a lot with that actually.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah, yeah.
And there was [inaudible].
Angela Rossi: Even, even--
Right, just vocal technique
that is completely different,
you know, with-- we don't want
to go too specifically, but,
you know, thrills that
only happen in that region,
specifically in that region.
>> Stephen Winick: Right, right.
Interesting.
>> Angela Rossi: And that
was amazing, you know.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yes,
it was really interesting.
Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: So
I want to invite you
because as you know Diego
Carpitella just soon
after that collaborated
with Alan Lomax
and did other trips
throughout Italy.
And we have those
field recordings here
at the Library of Congress.
So we're going to invite you
back anytime you want to come.
>> Angela Rossi: We can't wait.
>> Stephen Winick: And we'll
show you those and we'll listen
to some more of the
same kind of recordings.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
So those are, those are great.
So, let's talk a little
bit about the instruments
in the group because some of
them will be instruments that,
you know, our audiences might
not be that familiar with, so.
>> Carmen Marsico: Mm-hmm.
>> Stephen Winick: What about
the bagpipes, Italian bagpipes?
>> Bjorn Wennas: Oh yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: Zampogna.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
It's actually going to-- I
didn't know this until I went
down to Southern Italy.
It is huge tradition down
there with the bagpipes.
And I don't think that a lot
of people are aware of it.
>> Carmen Marsico: Mm-hmm.
>> Bjorn Wennas: But it's funny
because they basically turn--
they basically turn
it inside out.
>> Stephen Winick: Yes.
>> Bjorn Wennas: And make some
reads on it and then play it.
>> Stephen Winick: When you
say it's a huge tradition,
it makes me laugh because some
of the bagpipes were so big.
>> Bjorn Wennas: I know again.
Yeah, they're--
>> Stephen Winick: That it looks
like you're dancing
with another person.
>> Bjorn Wennas:
-- they're amazing.
>> Angela Rossi: Yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
The first time I've really
strongly experience is what we
were in Naples, Carmen and
I for Christmas and it is--
and particularly in Christmas
time, the shepherds--
well, nowadays is just
bagpipe play which--
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah
>> Bjorn Wennas: -- but they
come down dressed as shepherds
and they play all these
pastoralis [phonetic]
on the streets of Naples.
So, it was funny, you
walk around and you see--
you pass a Gucci store and next
to it is a guy with his bagpipe.
>> Carmen Marsico: And usually
the tradition is the bagpiper is
going to play with the another
musician that plays charamela,
which is the-- our
[inaudible] version.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Carmen Marsico: So they
always go in pairs like that.
>> Stephen Winick: So it's
a double reed mouth blown
double reed.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah, yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: Right.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: Then--
>> Carmen Marsico: And
then plays both of them.
Yeah. And actually the charamela
comes from Napoli, Naples.
And the bagpipe comes
from, well--
[ Inaudible ]
From Alfonso Toscano,
the leaves--
>> Stephen Winick: Oh,
oh, you're speaking
about his instrument, yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: The Zamponia
itself was an instruement--
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah,
it's been made by [inaudible]
in Italy, though, yes.
>> Angela Rossi: Part
of the same, you know,
era and they do-- the two,
you know, musicians, they go--
in Christmas time, some hire
them to go to their apartment
to play the novena so
to play this traditional
Christmas music.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: And
it's still happening,
the Christmas very, very early.
>> Carmen Marsico: Well you
should talk about your--
[ Multiple Speakers ]
-- That's a very
important instrument.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yes.
So I play a particular guitar
called a chitarra battente.
And I was mentioning
John LaBarbera before.
He was definitely a person that
help me develop playing that.
And so, it's-- it is
basically a baroque guitar
but with steel strings
and medal frets.
And in the west, baroque guitar
has gut strings and gut frets.
But other than that, it
is very much the same.
And it has something
called re-entrant tuning.
So as you drag your
finger across the strings,
this got di-da-da and then
it jumps up and octave again,
ba-ba, which is-- but
it's the same strings
as you play a guitar which
is very confusing that all
of a sudden you would
jump up an octave.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas:
Anyway, I learned a bunch
of different techniques
both from John
and from another chitarra
battente player in Italy.
And it is a particularly
an instrument that you find
in Calabria and in
Gargano and Puglia
and in Salento and Campania.
So those are the-- I would
say probably these areas
that has the strongest
tradition.
So it's very much an
instrument that's remain
from history, you
know, up to now.
>> Stephen Winick:
It's really interesting
because it gives it some
of the early music feel and
yet it's a surviving aspect
of folk tradition that a lot
of people just don't know about.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
It's-- Outside of
Italy here in America.
I don't know how many place--
me and John and maybe--
>> Angela Rossi: And
probably you two, yes.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
I would say it's probably a few
other people that maybe doesn't,
but I think him and I,
we all know once they
do it professionally.
>> Stephen Winick:
Right, interesting.
And then there's-- you--
there's another guitar player
in the group.
So let's talk about
Yusy's [assumed spelling].
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
So, Yusy he plays a mandola,
beautiful mandola actually
that I snapped up
in Napoli from 1960.
And he plays--
>> Carmen Marsico: The oud.
>>Bjorn Wennas: -- the
oud and classical guitar.
We both play classical
guitar and mandola.
The mandola and the
chitarra battente,
they complement each other
very much like in the sound
in both double strings and--
but he has a little bit more
body to it, which is nice.
When he plays lines, I play
arpggiated park or strumming.
But the oud, I think that was
one of the things when we--
when he was starting in a band,
that we really want to bring
in his knowledge of music from
the middle east and the language
that he spoke because we--
as I was mentioning before
when we're looking at the music
from the southern Italy,
we saw all these influences
and there was definitely
one influence
that we wanted to enhance and--
>> Carmen Marsico: Make
people aware of it.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: Make
it shine in the music.
And it's funny because
Yusy always--
when I remember when we re
talking to him about it,
he said, well, let's be careful
because I don't want to look
like I'm appropriate in
anything from the Arab world
and I'm just trying to
make my contribution with--
I think we loved him just for
that, just for that, you know,
approach of respect because
that's what we always try
to grab, you know,
towards the music.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Other than
that, I think you almost--
all the instruments are--
instruments that you find
and people know about the
violin, et cetera, the bass--
>> Carmen Marsico: The
recorders, right, in the room.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
But the-- But I guess
the most particular part
in the music is the--
what Fabio play is the
different tamburellos.
And I don't know who
it was that said that,
it's very much the
heartbeat of the music.
And you want to hear
that boom, boom, boom.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
It gets you going,
lots of triplets
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
And he has several
different ones for different--
>> Bjorn Wennas: Oh, yeah.
I mean, yeah-- well--
>> Angela Rossi: It's
a selection, yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah, I
was going to say like yeah,
you saw three here
tonight, yes, I don't know.
>> Angela Rossi: Right.
>> Bjorn Wennas: His
girlfriend is crying.
>> Angela Rossi: And,
you know, if he sees--
if you make him sit down
sometimes and talk about the--
his instruments and
the tradition
of the instruments,
it's pretty amazing.
He was-- we were giving a
lecture recently in Arkansas
and he-- you know, they both
talked about the instruments.
And I learn things that
I totally didn't know
about the frame, drums,
the tambourines of Italy.
And one major difference
for example is there is a big
tambourine that's called a
tammora that is used to play
a certain style of music
in Naples, the tammurriata.
And then other different
tambourine, different sizes are
from different regions
and so areas--
>> Bjorn Wennas: Specialized,
so different techniques.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
Like from Calabria,
they have one in Apulia,
in Salento they have another--
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
Obviously all of
them and things--
>> Angela Rossi: And
different claves, you know,
different claves for different
styles, but today we kind of--
we play different-- there
was a Calabrian rhythm,
which is a certain
Calabrian rhythm within.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Oh I can
say that Calabrian sparka,
spaka napoly, napoly sparka,
[clapping] sparka
napoly napoly sparka,
sparka napoly napoly
naploy napoly napoly napoly.
>> Stephen Winick: There you go.
Excellent.
Yeah. Great.
So let's talk a little
bit about arranging.
So you've got all these
great instruments,
how do you decided what's
going to be on [inaudible].
>> Bjorn Wennas: Well--
oh, how do I decide?
I don't know.
>> Carmen Marsico:
Well, you hear it.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Well, yeah,
but I would say-- thank you.
I would say I hear
it quite often.
The-- for example like
when we do new songs,
songs that I've written, right,
then is-- I write very much,
try to write very much
to everybody's strength
as a player.
And-- But if we, for
example, like if we pick
up on a field recording and
I have a skeleton basically,
sometimes a broken skeleton, you
have to mend it back together.
It was like did she
mean to sing that?
It's just supposed to
be my tone in there,
or she's out of tune, you know--
>> Angela Rossi: What kind of
harmony do you put under there.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Right.
So, I would say like a lot of
times I start out with a rhythm
and from the rhythm,
I get the idea of the
where we want to take it.
I mean like sometimes maybe
we hear it immediately like--
but if I don't hear it
immediately I would say
like you often start
with some kind of rhythm
and I get the feeling
for what kind
of direction I want to go in.
>> Carmen Marsico: Well, for
example if you think of--
I mean, the first tarantella
would be today [inaudible].
When we heard the field
recording for that,
there was a clapping
going on in the background
and it's tambourine, I think,
was there or maybe not.
>> Bjorn Wennas:
No there was only--
>> Carmen Marsico: No, only
voice and the clapping.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Only
voice and clapping.
>> Carmen Marsico:
So-- and you said, OK,
their clapping has to stay.
We need to keep it,
that's very cool.
And then because of tarantella,
it's not a tarantella
if you don't have a tambourine
and we needed to have that.
And then we thought, well, let's
do this slightly different,
let's do just chitarra battente,
that goes together with a groove
and the clapping
and the tambourine.
And that's how it works.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Oh, oh,
oh, I have to say something
as an arrangement, and I would
say that probably other people
that arranges this music
contemporary like, for example,
there's another group
in Apulia [inaudible],
and they arrange
their [inaudible].
So quite often, this music did
the traditional tarantellas.
We have two chords.
Right? We have a one
chord, we have a five chord.
Let's play that for five minutes
now like-- and you have--
as an arranger, you have
to do something with that,
so I have invented
all kind of ways
that you can possibly re-imagine
these two chords turn them
inside out creating baselines
using the parallel minors, the--
>> Carmen Marsico:
And then I mean--
>> Bjorn Wennas: --
anything that [inaudible].
>> Angela Rossi: Sometimes
there is sneaks in,
maybe a little something
different, right, not always.
>> Bjorn Wennas: But, you know--
not always but quite often.
And you just have to think
about like what can I
do with this, you know.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: And also
another thing that I notice,
not always because sometimes
like the arrangements
are perfect and pristine.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Thank you.
>> Angela Rossi: But I
think sometimes it's great
when they're not because we--
then when we get to
play, then it's--
>> Carmen Marsico:
We get more ideas.
>> Angela Rossi: -- We get more
ideas, we get some ideas and,
you know, he's thinking,
oh perhaps, you know,
if you play this
an octave higher,
it's going to give
a different effect.
Perhaps, you know, if in
certain instruments, you know,
you get to see the
potential of their instrument
that maybe you didn't
know about.
And I think that's a
really fun aspect of it.
When we come up with
breaks and all the sound,
this would be a really
good break or--
>> Bjorn Wennas:
Yeah, absolutely.
They are not untouchable
to my arrangements.
>> Stephen Winick:
But it's interesting
because it shows how your
musical training is interacting
with this tradition.
So if you're inside
the tradition,
those limits are there but you
don't recognize them as limits
that you can break or
that you can play with.
But if you come from outside
and have this musical training,
you can-- you recognize the
limits for what they are
and say, well, OK,
so how are we going
to deal with this one part?
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
So it's really interesting
to hear you talk about that.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: So great.
So, yeah, so one thing
that we didn't mention
that when we were talking
about instruments is it might
be interesting to people
that you include an
electric base in the group.
What was the reason behind that
or the-- or how do you use it.
>> Bjorn Wennas:
Well, the reason for--
I mean that we're not going
to take the credit for that
because there are a lot of
bands in Italy who does that.
>> Angela Rossi: We heard--
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas:
No, no, absolutely.
And I think that we all
wanted, we all wanted to have
like a slightly more modern
sound of-- you know, we can--
we-- I mean quite often we
played clubs, and, you know,
you want to have the power on--
>> Angela Rossi: Also
outdoor festivals.
For example in Italy
or Chicago, it's nice--
>> Bjorn Wennas:
You need the bottom.
>> Angela Rossi: -- Right.
You need the bottom
sound and I feel
like sometimes it's a
bridge to connect also
to a younger audience that
connects to the element
that now is so popular,
you know.
And--
>> Carmen Marsico: I mean, yeah,
it really-- I mean in reality,
we have to face the fact
that we are in 2018.
And like some stages if you
don't have that low end,
you're really going to lose.
>> Angela Rossi: You disappear.
>> Carmen Marsico:
Yeah, a little bit.
But then other times,
we found ourselves
like in Kansas City
in the room--
>> Angela Rossi: In the room.
>> Carmen Marsico: -- yeah.
Well, we-- Jeff with bass was
there too with a small theme,
but having just a little bit
yeah, or sometimes we play--
something, this little place in
Boston, and it's a book store
and that we kept it
really acoustically,
acoustic because I mean it would
be an overpower in the rooms,
so I guess that it's-- you
know, we needed that to make it
as we said more modern and--
>> Stephen Winick:
So I should mention
that I first met the
band in Kansas City
in a very small hotel room at
the Folk Alliance conference.
So that's what was
being alluded to their--
>> Bjorn Wennas:
One-thirty in the morning.
>> Stephen Winick: That's right.
And they were playing a set
for, you know, a few of us,
there were-- there was-- it
was pretty full actually.
>> Angela Rossi:
I was surprised.
>> Carmen Marsico: It
feels like a blur in.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: I
was very surprised
because there's so
many people just--
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
I don't remember at all.
>> Angela Rossi: -- at 2
o'clock in the morning.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
But--
>> Bjorn Wennas: We played
one, even later, we played one,
I think at like about 2:30.
>> Carmen Marsico: Three.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Three--
>> Carmen Marsico:
Something like that.
>> Bjorn Wennas: -- 3 a.m. Yeah.
And we were like--
>> Carmen Marsico:
And still people--
>> Bjorn Wennas: And we were
like no one is going to come.
And then like-- by the end, it
was like the room was packed.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
So the Folk Alliance
International is an organization
that promotes folk music
and they have these
showcases every year.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: And this is--
you guys showcase
this past year.
Had you been to a Folk Alliance?
>> Angela Rossi: No.
>> Bjorn Wennas: No.
That was first time, I think.
>> Stephen Winick: What was
your impression on that?
>> Bjorn Wennas: That was shock.
>> Angela Rossi: It
was so much fun though.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah, yeah.
We have so much fun.
It's-- It was amazing.
We plan to go back
again this year.
>> Angela Rossi: Which will
be in Canada, if I'm not--
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, yeah.
And that brings up
another one more question
which is you'd mentioned
playing in Italy
at festivals and playing here.
Do you perceive a difference
between playing in Italy
versus playing for
American audiences?
>> Angela Rossi: Yeah.
A little bit.
I do. I do it a little bit.
You do fear that that's
where the tradition
belongs definitely.
I've-- When you-- But it's
just the way that they all grew
up with the music
and/or it was just taught
to them especially the
dance because the element
of the dance is very
tight to some
of these music that we play.
And so that's the first
thing you see people--
young people in Italy just--
>> Carmen Marsico: Going crazy.
>> Angela Rossi: -- dancing
like the traditional
dance and-- but really--
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah, yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: -- with a
lot of passion and knowledge,
really, you know, the--
>> Carmen Marsico:
Sometimes they, you know--
Well, we played in the very
south, but we play more
in the center where the
tradition wasn't really the same
than they had, but because
anyway they are exposed,
they could dance
and know what to do.
Sometimes maybe they don't
but they dance anyway.
So, yeah, it's-- I actually
lately even here, I've noticed
that more people are aware of
like only where they let it be.
>> Angela Rossi: They
connect more without--
yeah, it's true,
over the years--
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: I agree.
I always saw a difference
in welcoming a style
that they're not used to
and just let themselves go
and hear it and maybe even
dance, you know, maybe even--
>> Carmen Marsico:
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
They just do their own thing.
That's what we usually say
because sometimes we have
the chance to teach some
of the dances, sometimes
there's no chances
and we say just feel free to
dance, you know, as you wish.
It's not like the ballet,
so you can really improvise.
Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick:
So one last thing.
I know that you've recorded
four CDs, I think, and you--
actually you're working
on the fifth.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: The first
three were mostly traditional
music of various times and now
you've moved into a process
where you write a fair
amount of the songs.
So you're doing essentially
original music in the styles.
How is the experience different
of doing your own songs
and the styles that you became
accustomed to as traditional?
>> Bjorn Wennas: Its fun.
>> Angela Rossi: Its really fun.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yes.
>> Carmen Marsico: It's--
>> Angela Rossi: Yeah.
>> Carmen Marsico: It's been
fun also like because we want
to still write in the dialects.
So, the previous city,
we wrote a pizzica.
And so I studied a little bit
this pizzica and just standing
like how do they-- and
try to think about rhythm.
And then we pick the theme and I
wrote it in some kind of dialect
that I-- by singing, you hear
and then you sort of like kind
of guessing what the word it
will be because it wasn't--
that I was-- I mean acquainted--
>> Angela Rossi: It's
not who we are, right.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
It was from-- so
far like Tejano.
Actually, no, wait, I
thought of like doing it there
from Salento, which is the area,
the southern part of Apulia.
And there are many
dialects there.
And I knew a friend that was
from there, and then I said,
so I'm going to write it, but
then you have to correct it.
And, you know, correct
it in your dialect
and then we'll keep
it like that.
So I did it and I found
their dictionary, try to--
because the metric
was very important.
So I couldn't, you know--
And so then I send it to him
and he said, oh,
maybe this one is--
So it was a little
collaborate, it was fantastic.
We did that.
Then we did it with
Neapolitan and for Neapolitan,
it was much easier because
she knows it very well.
I'm more-- definitely
know a little bit more.
>> Angela Rossi: And
we have our mamas.
>> Carmen Marsico: Well,
your dad at that time--
>> Angela Rossi: My dad.
>> Carmen Marsico:
-- and then your mom.
>> Angela Rossi: Yeah.
>> Carmen Marsico: And then
we started writing also
in the dialect of my parents.
And then it was like
collaboration
between me and my mom.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Carmen Marsico:
Like, so what--
and then my mom would call
her sister, it's like,
so maybe we should
say like that.
>> Angela Rossi:
And then friends.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah, yeah.
>> Angela Rossi: It's like
all the friends were involved,
no, it's like this.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
And like, no.
And, you know, different
opinions
because it's not this
type of language anyway.
But it was wonderful
to actually--
>> Stephen Winick: Involve them?
>> Carmen Marsico: --
involve them and make them--
we make this whole thing alive.
It's really great.
>> Angela Rossi: And for
this last album which is done
and I was so happy because
we just received our sample
with the cover and everything
covered out, beautiful.
And in this album, we
definitely, you know,
try to be very creative with the
writing aspects and, you know,
and lyric wise to try to-- I
just wanted to say something
about the substance of the text.
Sometimes you-- we try now,
we're really trying to talk
about personal experience
and what we see and we try
to just express our
thoughts through the music.
So it's-- the text
component is important too.
So we talk about
immigration, the way we--
the way people are
dealing with it,
the way we see it [inaudible]
and sometimes we don't
agree, you know, and-- yeah.
>> Bjorn Wennas: And then
the new album is called
Mediterraneo, so it's very much
about the crisis of migrants
and across the Mediterranean
Sea.
>> Stephen Winick: Interesting.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Angela Rossi:
So how, you know,
the stories of these people
that they come, you know,
and leave everything
behind just like we did.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Well--
>> Angela Rossi: To--
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Well a lot of our ancestors,
that's what I mean--
>> Bjorn Wennas: Yeah.
Oh OK, OK.
>> Angela Rossi: -- not me.
Me, yes, so I went for better
opportunities but I wasn't,
you know, in despair,
we weren't in despair.
We are very lucky migrants, but
there's different levels of--
>> Stephen Winick: Sure.
>> Angela Rossi: --
you know, and today--
>> Carmen Marsico: Well,
we actually talked also
about our experience
as immigrants because--
well, when you move somewhere
else and you live far away,
and when you go back,
you feel kind of awkward.
And, you know, people--
I mean I don't know,
but like people call
me the American and I'm
like it's Italian, but
because I've been living here
for a long time.
So I mean it's-- we
have a lot to say.
There's a lot.
>> Angela Rossi: Yes.
>> Carmen Marsico: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Well,
it's also interesting
because you're going back there
with some traditional music
from that region but
then also some songs
that you've written
in their dialects.
And so there's this sort
of strange combination
of foreignness and
belonging that's sort
of natural to what you're doing.
One thing I notice is you did
win an independent music award
for the most recent CD, but it
was in the traditional world
of category even though a lot
of the songs are original.
>> Angela Rossi: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: Do you
have any feelings about that?
I mean--
>> Carmen Marsico:
Well, I do have--
>> Bjorn Wennas:
I'm feeling great.
>> Stephen Winick:
You're happy--
yeah, that's why
[inaudible] I would be too.
>> Carmen Marsico: I do have--
I have a comment to say.
Two years ago we played for
a-- for this event, small--
I mean, small event, we actually
played, just me and Bjorn
because she couldn't
come in Basilicata
in this little village and
they were given some kind
of recognition to people
that had immigrated all
over the world from the village
and they came back and they say,
oh, you did this, whatever.
And we were asked to have
sing-- to play some songs.
And we did some traditional
song of our self.
And then I had a woman come
and say, oh, this is beautiful.
But I recognize some, some
other I don't recognize, but--
like it's really great.
So she did not thought--
they didn't think that
they were not traditional.
>> Angela Rossi: And
she was from there.
>> Carmen Marsico: And
She just thought I don't
know that song, you know.
And I was, oh, this
is really amazing.
>> Angela Rossi: It's
like we're getting part
of the standards now that
we have the traditional--
>> Bjorn Wennas: And also I
can point to the last album,
it was actually nominated
in Italy too as a part
of like the traditional music
prize that they give up there.
And also there was a bunch
of music journalists
particularly one,
Shiro de Rosa [assumed
spelling] who--
he writes song lines and he is
from Naples and then-- I think.
And he wrote very
interesting things
about like how we take
Southern Italian tradition,
put it on its head, mess around
a little bit with it and come
up with something
new and he like that.
You know, it is like, you know.
Because, you know, any
time you treat it as a--
as an object that you--
>> Angela Rossi: A
museum piece, right?
>> Bjorn Wennas: -- Yeah,
you can't touch it, you know,
it has to be a living organism
and the fact that, you know,
for example, Fabio, Carmen
and Angela, they went here
and then they write
music about it, you know,
about their homeland and
their experiences here,
in the tradition, it's
all part of folk music.
>> Angela Rossi:
So we don't mind
to be called traditional
or non-traditional.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Or foreigners.
>> Stephen Winick: Well, thank
you so much on that note.
I think we can say we've
talked a lot about your music
and we really hope to hear
more of it in the future.
And we were so happy
that we had you here
for a homegrown concert.
And we'll meet again
especially when you come
to hear our Alan
Lomax recordings
of Italian folk music.
>> Angela Rossi: Thank you.
>> Bjorn Wennas: Thank you.
>> Stephen Winick: Thank you.
>> Angela Rossi: Thank
you for having us.
>> Carmen Marsico: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov